hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to zen and the art of
transhumanism now it's a big title but I
don't exactly know what this game is
about except for pottery oddly enough
that's the only description that I've
seen about the game and I don't know how
that plays into the actual hello hi who
are you
oh hello world or your robot oh you're a
cool robot
greetings acara 184 welcome to the job
h+ cores expects you to be an excellent
human upgrade crafter feel free to
inspect you work zone until you are
comfortable let me know when you're
ready to accept requests yes master
thank you well that's a little bizarre I
don't have a gamepad am I supposed to be
playing with a gamepad I could do that
I'm gonna do that just in case because
it seems to be the a button is important
here hello
you can check your finish pieces here
this is the operating theater here
you'll receive our clients and you'll
install the necessary upgrades are you
ready to get started on clients no I
wanna I wanna study a little longer no I
want to study a little longer give me a
few more seconds on this one this is the
Potter disk with it you will shape
handcrafted limbs and organs for the
clients oh this is the official H cork
transhumanist wiki you should check it
to memorize some useful designs and know
more about their effects okay this
interface holds data on this month's
client list with it you can keep track
of clients progress in satisfaction okay
sounds bizarre and interesting I'm
totally into it yes I am ready why can't
why is this no a gamepad no work on
there alright whatever
perfect first one incoming oh hi whoa
hello hi human you're naked why are you
naked why are you naked here I once
again ask why are you naked hello check
clients file I guess Caroline Kramer 19
click
writer no matter what I do I can't get
my follower count over 1000 please help
me okay
alrighty then so the Enchantress
increase your online social network
charisma
well that sounds important I I think
that's what we need okay
wait oh ah so I need to make that
pattern in the pottery oh that's what it
meant
Oh oh my goodness gracious
wow that is cool why why why oh man oh
that's cool so I can't remember what I'm
designs I need to actually look at the
design can I get a design
oh I push it oh I boo [ __ ] oh that's so
cool that's a butt plug that's a dildo
that's another dildo there we go that's
what I want okay and I gotta get [ __ ] no
goddamnit I wanted I didn't mean to push
that sorry I don't think this is the
right no god [ __ ] damn it that's no
what I'm trying to do huh okay oh I feel
like this would be easier with the mouse
then it would be with hey let me try it
with the mouse maybe I never should have
done it with the with oh gee yeah okay a
little more precision oh god oh god oh
god
oh I [ __ ] it up I [ __ ] it up I
[ __ ] it up reset okay there we go good
thing that's possible and I don't
understand where she's gonna shove this
to make it all acceptable
it's like momentum basis it's super
weird
more a little more whoa whoa whoa there
we go there we go
nailing it yeah nailed it nailed it
nailed it and that BAM [ __ ]
okay got it production compete these ten
to it I got it okay let's do that
increase your social network online it
looks beautiful it looks beautiful let's
give that to you install modules with
that BAM Oh bloom ski whoa huh how how
will that work nice dick what is going
on
you seem pissed that will mate but will
that make her happier probably
considering it's what she wanted okay
majima soon 40 there's a new gang in
town that has been causing problems and
they're strong I need to get rid of them
at any cost
okay I got I got the right thing to
shove up your butt for something like
that it looks a lot like this the night
okay
the night you say well we'll try it I
don't know if it'll be good designs nope
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] why the double press why
Oh come on buy the double press there we
go god damn it okay okay here we go all
right here we go all right here we go
here we go here we go
hey hey hey oh it's so hard oh my god
it's so hard to do oh my brain my brain
oh oh god you don't understand oh really
hurts my brain no I can't do that with
the gamepad I just I just can't holy
[ __ ] I can't oh my god I've never seen
like more difficult controls okay here
we go oh it's so frustrating
all the controls they hurt my brain oh
the controls aren't my brain oh oh hey
hey there we go I got this the knight
incoming I'm a robo I'm good at my job
and there we go okay
holy [ __ ] oh my god that's so difficult
to do got it know that here we go
doesn't look very useful shut up I
didn't even try to do that I'm gonna do
this install modules I got the night go
for it shove it right up in his going
we'll play them okay it's gonna cause
some serious damage hello
nice beard and dick how you doing I
wonder if that was a sensible on our
side probably okay Geordi de Paco 28
game designer no matter what I do I
can't make a good game I want to make a
game that it's critically acclaimed by
press and public well I don't know how
my thing is gonna be doing that and I
don't know why you guys keep showing up
naked to my office not that I mind very
much but it's just a little distracting
okay the bishop genuinely enlightens
your mind maybe I should just make some
of all of these and that would make
sense right
oh I'm getting it now so like if I use
the right tool in the right spot I won't
need to worry about doing it around
because it'll just flow it all around
ah it cool it cool it work it work okay
that's really cool I didn't know that
I'd be playing a game entirely based
around sculpting even though that's what
I said is beginning of this I didn't
know that the entire game was sculpting
oh that's my best one yet oh that's a
beaut oh that's a beaut okay I'm just
gonna keep making them all I'm gonna do
all the making of them right here okay
so the the answer is fairly obvious for
these things
tada BAM done the prints okay that's
good okay so I'm gonna keep making them
ah I get music while I work I don't
typically listen to music on my own
anyway so this is bizarre okay so I
believe this goes on the bottom full
term done and I need not this one
eventually I'll need this one but come
back to that one this one which is gonna
do this whole son of a [ __ ] section
right just like oh that's fun
art is fun I like art yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's more like it
that's more like it the Empress okay got
it okay this one huh alrighty then I
think I know how to do this
oh that's so cool
oh man I'm easily excitable but this
actually is legitimately interesting to
me like a lot of parts of games is like
you know that a lot of people forget
there's story and then there's gameplay
and for some reason this is this
gameplay is like really appealing to me
like I've never really played anything
like it so it's it's just bizarre and
odd but it's an interesting experience
and that's it's like fascinating because
it's not often something that people get
here we go okay oh that almost perfect
that almost perfect the temple oh I'll
be right with you game designer you just
stand there naked for a few more hours
I'll be done oh yeah cuz now I'm gonna
be working on the butt plug I kind of
forgot that that was gonna be a pretty
much thing I'm gonna do here we go what
plug complete perfectly ready for
insertion the pond sure it is more like
the pound because it's gonna pound never
mind sure buddy Beedie Beedie Beedie
Beedie boink and the boink okay there we
go
and he blink okay
oh no oh no no no Oh perfect
Oh goddamn it I'm a [ __ ] failure I'm
a failure to everything I tried to be
too perfect and I just cocked it all up
I can't it all up production complete
the snowflake oh yes oh yes indeed the
beautiful snowflake done okay but AG the
cloud oh okay I don't know if there's
any more plug that one that one this one
I think this is the last one I'm pretty
sure anyway
[Music]
hey hey hey hey okay I think that was
the very last one the void okay so
you're gonna need ah probably this one
the bishop have fun with that up in your
gut buy everything you need
I'm sure this vis Elbert will come up
with some cool games now but does this
kind of success benefit him yeah
probably
let's see what do you need let's see
Peter Garfield 52 doctor chemist I spent
my old life in research and I never had
a girlfriend please I want to have sex
I wanna [ __ ] a lot of people well I've
got just the thing probably empowers
your overall sex appeal okay just have
that in there whip that out when you're
ready and you'll be great to go
I'm sure this guy's sexual life is about
to bloom I just hope that'll be enough
for him well maybe maybe not but who am
I to judge
Patricia Lafayette 97 singer I've
enjoyed a fanciful life now I can't help
but feel my end is near I don't want to
abandon the stardom in my fans please do
something
you know lady you may just be a pile of
pixels but for 97 years old
hot damn you're looking pretty good I
mean I just want to calls him like i
sees him okay lifespan you got it shove
that right up in there you're fragile
enough that you can take it Patrice you
just bought yourself some extra time did
you know that immortality was considered
a curse by some ancient cultures I think
I consider it a curse too let's see that
clients file Carolina Kramer clickbait
writer no matter what I do I oh wow my
follower count went wild thanks to you
but now there's a lot of [ __ ]
caressing me well that's that's no good
I suppose
I forgot that over here there's actually
something that I can do to check up on
me which folder do you want access okay
completed jobs no completed jobs well
there might be some completed jobs what
are you talking about
Carolina Kramer okay anyway so yeah
that's fine so I'm just doing follow-ups
now so now what do you want I'm not sure
eliminates
the need for social acceptance maybe I
should have installed that first that
would have been good
you freed her from her dull craving well
done hello what is wrong with you you
decided to put on some clothes
brutal I've never had so many good ideas
I even won a Ludum dare still I feel
like I won't ever surpass hideo kojima
okay
suppresses any violent impulses I don't
think that's the right one removes every
type of ambition ah great that's good
for the human spirit I'm sure his ego
won't do him any good you just saved him
oh yeah it feels like it let's see what
about you
I feel so full of life thank you my fans
already noticed it nevertheless how long
will this last can I get some more um
maybe maybe not let's see cancels any
carnal impulses concedes uncondensed
atonal acceptance towards death okay
have some of that lady I bet that feels
good to be free from oneself that's the
summit of any existence nice dick
alright amazing I could feel their bones
breaking under my knuckles
however they brought even stronger
fighters now make me stronger
okay how about it how about a nice butt
plug for you she cancels any carnal
impulses suppresses any violent impulse
there you go up your button Charlotte
for you just made the world a lot more
peaceful you did well see what about you
I'm exhausted I'm so happy thank you so
much sadly there are still some beauties
who could resist my charms okay what if
I double up I kind of want to double up
on this guy I wonder what would happen
if I did I really wonder what would
happen and one second I'm gonna make him
up another prince
because I think it'd be funny to see
what happens so this is probably not
gonna do him a whole lot of good I wanna
see I'm just a little curious I'm gonna
make you even more irresistible have
some of that go good
I'm sure this guy's sexual life is about
to bloom oh hi
I just hope that'll be enough for him
all right welcome back exhausted god
damn it
so what happens if I just completely
dominate this guy with only princes I
mean there's every possibility that I
could do that and I think in the
Inventure allottee what it's trying to
say is that he would be completely
replaced by robotic parts at that point
and then he would no longer be human but
at the same time removing all these base
impulses is also taking away their
humanity so what in reality is better
I can't just remove all of his sexual
desires would that be good I don't know
Who am I to say maybe in this one person
maybe maybe he really should have
non-stop sexual bliss as long as he may
live okay so I made three more of these
things no no no no get out there and and
and end it that's not what I meant to do
I know it's not very useful I know I
know I know but I made three more of
these things because that might be just
enough to completely transform this
person into a robot have some of that
I'll see you around the bend
okay sexual life about to bloom huh all
right let's give you another one another
one why don't you have fun with that ah
hello welcome back you want one more
I've got one more for you you're gonna
be a sexual dynamo let me just make sure
like what is the actual saying exhausted
let's see I wonder if anyone's actually
gonna be able to have sex with you once
you're completely Robo welcome to the
club
oh I need to make one more than I need
to make just one more okay buddy here
you go
glass one you'll ever need Oh buddy boo
boo have fun
wait what hello what are you
well this games broken fine be neutered
there have that drawn get out of here
whoa well done a karo 184 you've
mastered the art of transhumanism now
you're ready to help us shape the new
world see you at the other side
understood master thank you okay but
that poor guy man he [ __ ] himself to
death and then right back around the
loop of life back into normal humanism
well there you go that is zen and the
art of transhumanism hope you enjoyed it
something to think about and then
something not to think about later on
but either way a fun game and oddly
enough fun to do some sculptures so
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]